mon sens la chair de ma chair si tes
jours sont obscures je serai ta lumière
je suis vite sans toi j'ai peur de dire
adieu je t'imagine près de moi et là je
me sens mieux mon fils je te regarde
mais doucement tu disparais alors je
m'accroche à toi et aux rêves que tu
étais car oui tu n'es pas né et je ne
verrai jamais mon fils ne m'en veux pas
mais je vais devoir d'apporter c'est
vrai je vais pas parmi les bons petits
poulets qui se passe et tu viens de
faire une petite pause
qu'est ce qui se passe où je vais sans
doute être à contre-courant abbaoui a
déjà weeks opté pour vous proposer de
réagir mais je n'ai absolument pas
compris ça paraît extrêmement gênantes
vous expliquer nyarugenge et non la
tariq qui arrivent et alors il ya bien
une équipe lors on comprend pas pourquoi
je dis atari aimé par les fans nous
interpréter une chanson que vous avez
composé vous comme par hasard va dans ce
sens que ça c'est l'origine mais oui tu
inverses là c'est moi finir nommé soit
précis quand et ça s'est passé comme ça
ça s'est passé comme ça qu'on aura zhari
chante accompagnée par les musiciens
tout ça était prévu c'est faux de a à z
dieu sait que j'adore vianney mais là je
suis sérieux mais je sais mais là cyril
je n'ai pas compris ce choix
professionnels de la télé pour lui
répond tu y es c'est juste que vous
retrouvez avec un candidat qui est un
vrai où elle crée une superbe changé moi
j'étais chez moi et me donc il faut
arrêter de voir le mal partout
allez je comprends guyanais était
bouleversée moi je vais vous montrer ça
juste parce que c'était une belle image
surtout verra débat là dessus
non mais j'en ai rien à carrer il faut
qu on dit les chéris mois pour moi c'est
une belle soirée
c'est beau ce vol je dise ça nous change
des idées on en a marre d'avoir des
trucs race rare voilà donc ça c'est bien
donc bravo et vianney il m'a ému voilà
on vous emmerde et que je retiens